a van's best friend may actually have
feathers feed supply stores across the
country this is so random
they've noticed a chicken buying trend
over the past year
some even had to limit their supply per
customer
i think it was fair man you know i think
it was all fear i think that the easiest
way when survival mode kicks in you
figure out how to feed your family
yeah a lot of people been doing this so
customers say they feel fulfilled
raising chickens
and happy they don't have to buy eggs at
the store anymore a reminder it is legal
to own some chickens here in clark
county they just have to be in a coop or
an enclosure but be sure to check city
and other local ordinances if you plan
on raising
your own i know a few people that do
that sherry and it's nice they just go
right out to the backyard yeah to the
hen house
yeah then there comes eggs and cook
their breakfast it's when your neighbors
have roosters that it's a little
disturbed
the crack of dawn yes oh and they're up
natural alarm clock